we should the shamash adore me I was at
my house I was asleep I've been cries
and they're like I was afraid my son
heard he was crying a lot there I tried
to calm her down but he was crying then
he did come down bc like me he's right
they said get out quick this building's
going to blow up I said what's going on
to be doing I need to get things from
there if I have things in their nap is
my son bankers I wanted to get my money
and get out of there wait was it what
did I do I threw myself on the floor and
lay out the bed to pick wife I was
scared i waited that's normal when you
hear everyone firing firing angry god
one cares so if i left my house they
would get away now pause while i was
waiting the building was trembling
underneath me when I looked up I saw
that fair parman head exploded lily I
didn't leave a boom I was scared baan
taad you don't know call Devon pompa
rocketboom I was on the first floor I
did not see the place like everything
we're at least where are the police then
I realized that it was the police firing
in the stairwell not the terrorists so
they could take me every soul and hear
what a morning throne I was under the
bed me my sin cara me could walk a lot
rossum it does your party lay exploding
tom de papa top-billed to make chocolate
chip Rafa exact mo polymeric module
premiered a small team premiered on
emotion hugely popular policy chapathi
pore size to tony la pelicula police
made apostle akkad sir louis callay
sloppily skeet emoji croquet set al
Otero risky tier menos de la política
tier porque el prom